so you like a lot or a little item in
Texas so you go ahead and guess
[Music]
all right y'all Thanksgiving is almost
here which means one thing and one thing
only pies I love pie
today I'm joined by the founder of sweet
lady Jane bakery which is awesome this
is Jane Lockhart y'all who brought us
some incredible pies today and I'm gonna
rank them for my favorites Elise
favorite which in reality there will not
be a least favorite because it's a pie
yeah right in front of it's not gonna be
awkward at all right and it's gonna be
great it's okay even if it's a least
favorite because I know her delicious
sale I'm just telling you it's pie Jane
so there's not gonna be a least favorite
drinks but okay what's up first I think
we should start with the apple pie okay
let's do it
oh my god I love your size of pie scoop
it up these isn't all butter must be bad
- so I just love apple pie so that's why
I put them on first um I love apple pie
Jane I'm gonna get this big bite
watching this Thank You cross - oh I
will Jane don't you worry okay goodbye
up you like oh great what are you doing
for dinner
wait I'll move it over these are another
because that was a minute don't take it
I'm still rain gonna put it we can
actually that's a good idea
I know I'm just gonna I just want to
make sure I like it
so this one is our southern pecan it's
got a little bourbon sigh oh my god I
love bourbon and I think you'll be able
to taste it - here we go oh my gosh
little taste of that
I mean they make these awesome desserts
like you just not eat them all the time
I take two or three bites Oh that
everybody makes me - oh my god all
occasions but everyday I could do it
this is amazing and it's the best but
I'm not lying the best pecan pie I've
ever had that that's a great compliment
do you say pecan or patan or pecan they
said you can wear for my Sepik on I see
hun yeah me too I think we're right
here's the thing guys this rating
situation I don't know how this is gonna
work because as you can tell
Jana our keep eating both the cherry
nuts
it is so good sherry is one of our newer
highest I started it probably about 10
years ago the bakery is open like 30
years now so I didn't realize I've been
along that around that long the open to
Santa Monica Nancy now I know I know the
end see no one I'm excited I'm about to
start the Cherry Pie I really want to be
friends with you Jay we can be buds oh
my gosh but I just oh yeah this is this
is great for me to hear because I always
said you know it's the customer feedback
well you know it's funny important I
love cherries like I've picked them up
trees need them but in my life I've
never had a cherry pie really I didn't
want to tell you that but I didn't want
to put pressure on but this is amazing
thank you it's a sour cherry and that's
what I think people respond to when they
don't they say they've never had oh good
I'm getting that crust that's gonna be
mine oh my god wait let me make room
okay
I love my pie plate this is our mixed
berry it's not typical for Thanksgiving
but we brought it today because it is
really a delicious probably put all
three berries in this like raspberry
blueberries and blackberries oh I love
all those berries okay it almost looks
like just sugary greatness it's about to
land on my mouth and my dog in my mouth
I can't use words oh my gosh your accent
is a luckiest man on the planet cept I
deprived him you don't need it ah I want
to be I want to be the test I want to be
you know you get to tattoo be the taste
tester I'm a very good taste tester wait
I need another plate wait here we go
you're gonna love that plate now we have
saved what generally is my favorite pie
for last so you like a lot or a little
I'm in Texas so you go ahead and get on
top this pie also has a little bourbon
in it really yes it makes it it sets us
apart from most this is my favorite is
this because here's the thing oh my gosh
I can taste the that is good okay I love
all the pies final ratings arm I'm gonna
be honest with you I don't know which
one and I'm always a pumpkin pie person
but it's either the pumpkin or the pecan
or my favorite and then he's all tied
for like right behind it you guys
there's no you're putting like the most
heavenly desserts in front of me you
wanted me to rank them are you insane
I'm not being nice I would just be like
oh this one is okay like no they're all
amazing I love you I'm gonna take this
from you and I'm gonna give you a hug
after I hand this off hold that pumpkin
pie plate in here don't take it Jane
seriously I mean this is the best
dessert y'all I'm not kidding I'm not
getting paid by her I'm saying I love
this pie all these pies you really can't
go wrong pick your favorite thank you so
much for coming through this alright
y'all enjoy some pies or don't if you're
dumb okay I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this